بمتابعه ردود الفعل من قبل الجانب
الاسرائيلي بدايه مما قاله نتنياهو هذه
الليله او ما نقلته وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
نقلا عن جانتس في رده على نتنياهو بوصفه
بما قام به بانه مباط
وبانه سيؤثر سلبا على اهداف هذه الحرب كيف
وجدت المؤشرات الاولى لردود الفعل في
الدخل الاسرائيلي على رد حماس حتى الان
على هذا
المقترح واضح سيدي العزيز يعني يوجد هنالك
انقسام كبير ما بين السياسيين
الاسرائيليين خاصه ما بين حزب جانس الذي
هو يشكل العمود الاساسي في حكومه الطوارئ
التي انشات بعد الحرب ولذلك كان راي جانس
وحزبه وايز كوت وزير الاركان السابق ه له
اهميه وحين يتحدث جانس انه يعني هذه
مماطله ما قام به
نتنياهو يوجد لها واقع كبير في اطراف
كثيره في المجتمع وخاصه تلك المؤيده
لعائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين بينما
نتنياهو من ناحيه اخرى خطب اليوم يعني
خلال المؤتمر الصحفي خطابا اي كلمات كبيره
ولكن في النهايه يعني السطر الاخير كان
انه لا يرفض البدء في مفاوضات يعني على
الرغم من كل ما قاله نتنياهو يعني نحن نسع
لنرى ما هو الخط الاخير وما هو السطر
الاخير اخير انه اريد مفاوضات بمعنى اخر
وهذا ما قاله كذلك من ناحيه اخرى الامريكي
بلينكن ولذلك يعني هي انا اعتقد انه يعني
كانه نتنياهو يريد ان يسوق الان يعني موقف
اسرائيلي متشدد جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت
يعرف انه هذا الموقف الاسرائيلي المتشدد
له معارضه كبيره جدا وهذه المعارضه غدا
سنراها في مجلس الحرب وفي يعني بالذات في
مجلس الحرب وحين ينتقل الى المجلس ال
الكابينيت الواسع الموسع كابينت السياسه
والح والدوله هناك يعني س نسمع اراء بنفير
واسم موتش ونحن نعرف جميعا يعني كل
المجتمع يعرف ما هي ارائهم ولكن سيبقى هل
اسرائيل على استعداد ان ترسل موفدا من
قبلها الى القاهره للاستمرار في المفاوضات
هذا هو الشيء الاساسي وانا اعتقد انه نعم
اسرائيل لا يوجد لديه اي طريق اخر غير
ارسال موفد من قبلها قد يكون رئيس المساد
او رئيس الش اذا ما ضممنا هذا السطر الذي
ذكرته دكتور محمود اذا ما قاله وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي هذا اليوم ايضا من داخل
تل ابيب بدايه اسالك من حيث الشكل ظهر
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي منفردا في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي ومن داخل السفاره
الامريكيه في تلابيب وبالتالي مذعن هذه
القراءه فيما يتعلق بال المقاربه
الامريكيه و
مقاربه نتنياهو
تحديدا يعني الاجتماع الذي قام به بلينكن
في مع نتنياهو كان ملفت للنظر اولا كان
هناك اجتماع شخصي بين الاثنين فقط ومن ثم
فتح الاجتماع ل شخصيات اخرى قياديه ولكن
ليس لكل مجلس الحرب يعني هذا كمان شيء مهم
انه اراد تحييد على الاقل جنس ان يكون جزء
من المفاوض من اللقاء نفسه و هذا الاجتماع
الذي كان يعني فقط ما بين بلينكن
ونتنياهو لم يرشح عنه تقريبا شيء لم يقل
لنا ماذا حدث هناك وماذا جرى هناك لا
نتنياهو تحدث ولا بلينك تحدث انما تحدثوا
فقط عن الاجتماع الموسع لانه لا يمكن
اخفاء ما حدث ذلك هناك لانه قد يعني يسرب
هنا وهناك اشخاص وهنالك توافق انا
باعتقادي ما بين موقف بلينكن وموقفنا
نتنياهو على الرغم من من من طريقه الكلام
المختلفه ما بين الاثنين انه الاثنين
قالوا في النهايه في مؤتمرين صحفيين
مختلفين في نفس المدينه ايه يعني انه في
نفس البلد انه نعم يوجد امكانيه للتفاوض
وسنستمر بالتفاوض وهذا هو المهم بالنسبه
لنا يعني اسرائيل لم تطرق الباب ولم تغلقه
على العكس وبلينك نفس فعل نفس الشيء ولذلك
القراءه هي قراءه ايه يعني ال
المستقبل وليس قراءه الماضي يعني نتنياهو
يريد ان ياخذنا الى الماضي حينما بدا
بالحرب وكان يعني وكان يتحدث باصوات
مرتفعه وصعد الى اشجار عاليه لكن الان
ماذا سيحدث غدا او بعد
غد حسب القراءه للاثنين لنتنياهو ول
بلينكن نعم و كذلك حماس سترسل موفد الى
القاهره وتبدا مفاوضات هناك وهنا القضيه
الاهم والمهم قد تكون هذه المفاوضات طويله
وصعبه ولكن حينما يدور العجل عجل
المفاوضات بدا بالدوران معنى ذلك انه
سياخذ هذا العجل الى مكان ما لن نبقى في
هذا المكان الذي نح بدوران عجل المفاوضات
كما سميته سيد محمود ايضا حتى اليوم في
المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
تم الاشاره الى الوضع في رفح هناك هواجس
هناك مخاوف حتى لدى الطرف الامريكي عبر
عنها بلينكن وقال حذرنا الجانب الاسرائيلي
بما يتعلق
ب المدنيين في اي عمليات تقوم بها اسرائيل
فيما يتعلق برفح وبالتالي ماذا عن هذا
المعطى هل هي ورقه للضغط كيف تقرا في
اسرائيل ام ان الامر نعم
وارد انا اقرا بطريقه تختلف قليلا ما اذا
ما حقيقه انتقلت العمليه العسكريه من خان
يونس الى غزه فمعنى ذلك انه اسرائيل تعترف
بفشلها العسكري من جديد مره ثالثه او
رابعه انظر ماذا حدث سيدي العزيز في
البدايه كنا في غزه وفشلت في مستشفى
الشفاء وفشل في وسط قطاع غزه وفشلت ووصلنا
الى خان يونس وحينما دخلت القوات الى خان
يونس سمعنا كل الاسرائيليين العسكريين
ومعظمهم يتحدثون يقولون لنا هناك استنار
موجود في خان يونس هناك موجودين في خان
يونس المختص الاسرائيليين طيب اذا تنتقل
الان انت الى الى رفح فمعنى ذلك انك فشلت
كنت تكذب على المواطنين الاسرائيلي ولات
كاسرائيل لا يعرف اي شيء لا لا كسياسي ولا
كعسكري
والان يعني يفتش في الظلام من جديد وكانه
يريد ان يفتش بالظلام من جديد في رفح فهذا
اعتراف بالفشل الاسرائيلي والمجتمع
الاسرائيلي سيفهم انه هذا الفشل عباره عن
فشل متراكم اكثر واكثر ولا طريقه اخرى
امامها هؤلاء
الاسرائيليين الذين فشلوا في كل مراحل
القتال الا الوصول الى التفاوض مثل ما كتب
124 قائد اسرائيلي و على عريضه وارسلوها
لنتنياهو لا يوجد امامه طريقه اخرى يريد
ان يظهر عنتريات و نتنياهو امام ناخبيه في
اليمين الاسرائيلي اهلا وسهلا ولكن هذا لن
يعني يفوت لن تكون فرصه سانحه لنتنياهو من
اجل ان يلتف على الم المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الذي بدا يفهم الحقيقه وراينا الليله يعني
هذا اليوم كان بيان مهم جدا من قبل
المتظاهرين الذين كانوا يتظاهروا قبل
الحرب اذا ما تذكر معي ضد التغييرات
القانونيه ان هنالك بيان جديد من المنظمين
انهم سينظم انفسهم من جديد للتظاهر ضد
نتنياهو من اجل الانتخابات القادمه فمى
ذلك انه في هنالك قوه ضاغطه جديده ستدخل
الى الساحه ال يعني الساحه الضاغطه
الاسرائيليه على نتنياهو نفسه وحكومته
وهذا مؤشر الى زياده الضغط المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على الاعيب نتنياهو